now your client Andrew Tate is accused
of human trafficking and forming an
organized crime group is that you stay
and you'd be funny you calling someone's
like he's forcing her to watch stay up
and watch
I'm gonna get sex trap I'm gonna get sex
trafficking they're gonna make up some
new name and say that I'm abusing my mom
to to make a YouTube video You're
loverboyed me
it's too funny true is that what they've
been doing here in Romania our client my
clients don't recognize the allegations
against them and their positions in
front of the prosecutors and in front of
the judge were not to recognize these
felonies that pretending to be done by
by them and they support us as a team of
lawyers with all the proofs and
evidences is needed to prove their
innocency the prosecutor is quite a
well-established person and would not
have brought this case if they didn't
have the evidence
legally yes but we are now in a phase of
Investigation is not a public phase of a
trial
and we are not talking in this moment if
the defendant is guilty or is not guilty
regarding a felony we are now in a phase
that the prosecutors didn't finish the
investigation so basically they just
locked them up so that they can finish
their investigation that is that not
illegal like it's not against the law
like don't you need evidence to even
have someone well it's Romania we still
are yet to get like real evidence all we
have were those two random girls that
Vice magically found in America they
would have to have a more solid case and
charges before they could arrest him and
detain him they could have brought him
in for questioning but and then let them
go but I know nothing about Romanian
criminal law we can't even ask those
questions what do you mean you didn't
get your Romanian criminal law degree to
present to take it to a trial we haven't
even got to the stage yet of saying is
them from the prosecutors and I think
that is very early to talk about the if
we have a case or you don't have a
strong case the prosecutor has also the
possibility not to send this case in the
court to be judged the prosecutor says
six alleged victims were found or women
at the Tate properties now were these
women being held there and exploited
from our point of view and from the
position
explained by our client I will say
definitely no
and as argument to my position is the
fact that when the investigator came in
the house of our clients the dwarfs were
opened all the girls had access to their
own phone number cellular data if
somebody is kept in a house against his
will
and he has his phone and he has the
possibility to post on social media on
Instagram to make tiktok content to talk
to the phone has the same possibility to
call one one two I mean all right so
this is a good point but this isn't like
like there's still scenarios where
people are like held against their will
or like they're being blackmailed or
something where they have access to that
but the real thing is like they just had
freedom like they could do what they
want they were they were working with
Tate on the on the webcam business damn
you really are tired I'm sorry Mommy
it's okay so you know cooking all day
cooking all day cleaning mopping
it's [ __ ] no but they all had freedom
like even if you watch the Tate's video
courses you see like the way they like
the strategies they teach aren't to like
just control women and like they make it
so they can't do anything yeah like it's
treat them like people I don't know
these are employees yeah exactly that he
was also having a relationship with
again and oh yeah I saw this too the
lawyer only had 45 minutes the time to
study the prosecutor's file he had like
45 minutes to go through like 100 Pages
it was so stupid
important to just leave the house or to
just leave the house because sorry
because we have the evidences by the
cameras from the house that the girls
were alone in the house that they uh
demand food but uh the that address they
were wardening food they were visiting
the town the mall they were making these
girls were just living life what do you
come like so what are you gonna come
after him for then this is this is what
I don't understand like they have access
to do whatever they want and he's still
going to be like no but and are they
also getting paid yes of course they're
getting paid they're employees so their
employees getting paid getting room and
board probably going shopping and buying
anything they want on Earth and they're
adults and then they're making it and
they're saying that this was sex
trafficking and there's plenty of girls
who quit too like they ran hundreds of
girls so why don't they interview the
ones that quit and had a peaceful exit
doesn't fit their agenda just because
they have the ability to leave and to
order food and go shopping that doesn't
mean that they're not being human
trafficked one other point another one
of the points that they made was like
Kate held all the access to to the
client's phone numbers and everything
like obviously obviously he's gonna be
the one that controls where all the
money's coming from yeah that's any
business I run an agency my editors
aren't talking to the clients right I do
it I have a middleman doing it because
then they could just go take them this
is this am I am I a trafficker this
makes no sense According to some experts
Andrew Tate employs the Loverboy method
which is to actually make the women who
are these experts we make them uh feel
under his control to handle all of the
finances and make them dependent on him
is it true that Andrew Tate has been
employing the Loverboy technique which
technically speaking is human
trafficking is a Pity that at this
moment legally speaking because the
investigation is not public I am not
allowed by the law to give more details
but I will give you that this lover boy
method is not sustained by the evidences
and we have contrary evidences and I am
wondering
were all the girls so in love with
Andrew Tate that all of the girls had
their brain washed by this method of
lover boy but ask his lawyer are you
aware of the numerous bits of video
evidence that are out there on YouTube
and elsewhere where your client talks
very explicitly about how he controls
the women who work for him it's very
clear from the public record that he's
already talked about the love bro
there's millions of McDonald's workers
who are convinced that their time is
worth nine dollars an hour to make a
company billions and you're out here
like he's convinced them to work for him
like bro every worker is convinced for
that job that's the boss's job is to
convince people that their time is worth
this much so he can keep the price
difference am I crazy am I losing it am
I actually going nuts Mom I'm done very
upset the boy technique and how to
control and manipulate these women okay
I don't know by heart all the videos of
Andrew Tate we are now in a phase that
we have to prepare other type of
defendings for our clients but I
wondering myself are you talking about
the real Andrew Tate on those videos and
what are you talking about a character
now this is going to be the most
essential part of this case is all the
cool and if there is a jury that decides
is going to distinguish between Andrew
take himself and Andrew take the
character online there is humor involved
there is certain things he's even
apologized for like on the PS Morgan
interview he did say he was wrong about
something because he converted on his
religion but other cool can you accept
that it's up to a jury at the end of the
day but his loyalt seems like he's gonna
make a point of putting it forward
because from my point of view as you
know nowadays A lot of people are
posting content on internet just to sell
an image
a character I am not sure that we are
talking
about the real person and retake in
previous videos
a posting or being able to pay off the
Romanian Criminal Justice System all we
hear about in the Celebrity Circle and
even in professional circles uh in every
industry they talk about developing a
personal brand right personal what's
your personal Brands they've got college
kids working on writing a paper about
what their own personal brand is instead
of just you know being a decent person
so everybody else on Earth can develop a
brand he develops a brand they don't
like the brand so now he's got to go to
jail for some snarky [ __ ] he said we
should all go to jail all of everyone on
YouTube
or being able to pay off the Romanian
criminal justice system so is that the
intention for Andrew Tate boasting about
paying off the Romanian Criminal Justice
System once again not taking any account
any personal accountability is Andrew
the bad one for using the system or is
it bad that the system allows him to do
that and then if you're acknowledging
that he was able to pay them off
wouldn't you think like maybe this whole
thing is a little bit corrupt him being
arrested in this country
I'm losing it now now that he's actually
uh you know in in jail is he going to
try to buy off the Romanian criminal
justice system oh yes okay
okay you you [ __ ] what a dumb dumb
question yes actually I am I was
planning on bribing uh as many heads of
state as necessary to get out of that
who told you yeah right oh like what a
stupid question got just what what even
happened even the lawyer's laughing he's
like this [ __ ] the Agents of the
Matrix as a lawyer I can say a big no
a big no he's going to have to go
through I don't want to answer the
comment anymore because I don't know the
statement of my client this declaration
of my client and
but again you might think that that's
just him playing a character
it's it is possible it is possible
everyone's playing a character on the
internet I was arrested he said very
enigmatically The Matrix has sent their
Asians look at me this is the Matrix has
attacked me
um can you explain what he means by that
I also don't know I heard the story of
Matrix but I don't know I have a smile
and he's just he's just smiling and
moving along like yep it's totally the
story it's totally sorry of The Matrix
[Laughter]
totally a serious profession and I
didn't ask my client about this metric
story because I think that is about
something on media platforms or Internet
platforms and I don't know
about this story with Madrid he thinks
there is a global system that includes
big Tech and governments and so on that
is trying to control and inhibit the way
pretty much everyone lives and that he
has been targeted by them some people
might even call it the Deep state if you
like
he has been targeted by them because he
is trying to emancipate young men now do
you believe that as his lawyer he said
that like that was like the like the
craziest conspiracy thing that has ever
been spoken like that there's people
that control the world like what a crazy
thought like no Joe Biden's the
President Joe Biden makes the decision
there's not people above him yeah it's
such a coincidence when Tate gets banned
on every single platform within a day
they make the vice documentary wait till
months to drop it arrest them and then
Tristan gets banned at the same exact
time his bank account's all Frozen at
the same time all this going down all
just a big coincidence that's all
there's no there's no you know Global
Elites coming into play none of these
people are going to islands and screwing
kids none of that's happening no none of
that's happening clown I don't believe
that a legit agent if you are talking
about my client believes you should ask
him at the proper time about this matter
this matter it doesn't have to do
anything with my activity as lawyer just
a final question then I know you visit
your client perhaps twice a day
sometimes how is Mr Tate doing
he is not very well
he's disappointed but he is willing to
to resist and to and to help the
investigators to find the truth to
present all the evidences that
he he has in his favor and he hopes that
he will take part it will take a part of
a Fat Track garbage complete garbage
[Music]
[Music]